die sieben ganz einfachen bauern regeln
für die regierung im impfstoff desaster
bauernregel nummer 1 wer zuerst kommt
mahlt zuerst
ja so war es auch mit dem impfstoff die
anderen haben es uns vorgemacht werden
wir noch geredet haben hatten die
anderen halt schon bestellt und während
wir noch geprüft haben hat selbst bei
exit boris schon los geimpft
mittlerweile sagt selbst die kanzlerin
das hat mich gewurmt bauernregel nummer
zwei wir ernten will der museen und
unsere tat waren millionen euro für die
impfstoffforschung das pflänzchen der
biontech impfstoff made in germany aber
für die ernte waren wir dann zu langsam
und zu blöd
regel nummer drei es ist nicht alles
gold was glänzt auch diese ganz einfache
regel bittere wahrheit im impfstoff
desaster deutschland eigentlich
vorzeigeland so pünktlich so verlässlich
so organisiert nicht so beim impfen uns
gesundheitsämter überfordert wie in
einem entwicklungsland unser land träge
unflexibel schlecht organisiert außen
hui innen pfui
regel nummer vier hochmut kommt vor dem
fall
tja auch diese weisheit hätte der
regierung helfen können hätte
stattdessen hat sie sich ganz zufrieden
auf die schulter geklopft im sommer man
sei so gut durch die krise gekommen
hochmut denn dann kam der fall dann kam
der zweite lockdown die zweite welle und
das impf drama tja und dann hat die
regierung auch diese einfache regel
nicht befolgt die regel nummer fünf
eigenlob stinkt ein satz der mir so oft
in den kopf kommt in diesen tagen auch
bei diesen worten der kanzlerin
also ich glaube dass im großen ganzen
nichts schiefgelaufen ist und wenn das
ganze land also längst weiß da ist
ordentlich was schiefgelaufen sagt die
regierung immer noch nix schief gelaufen
dass du schauen wir damit kommt die
regierung nicht durch so wichtig deshalb
regel nummer sechs vor der eigenen türe
kehren das hat die politik in diesem
impfstoff desaster vollends verlernt
verantwortung übernehmen anpacken fehler
eingestehen nichts da stattdessen
wegducken zuständigkeiten hin und her
schieben und mit dem finger immer auf
die anderen zeigen und dann ist da noch
diese bauernregel regel nummer 7 wenn
der november kraft im nächsten jahr der
bauer lacht erst im nächsten jahr müsste
es eigentlich heißen
so nämlich es mit diesen unsäglichen
november hilfen das geschäft der wirte
friseure händler
es ging im november ordentlich krachen
wegen des zweiten lok bei uns die hilfen
aber gab es nicht mehr im november
sondern erst im nächsten jahr
das ist die bittere wahrheit für
millionen deutsche und eine von sieben
ganz waren bauernregeln in dieser
chronik